obviously einsteinium has a slight
resonance for me because many people
think that I look like I'm Stein though
of course I'm staying when he was young
look nothing like me
einsteinium the first time that was
discovered was actually in the debris of
a nuclear bomb which has then prompted
people to make it in a more rational and
less destructive method ever since as
far as I know that einsteinium has
absolutely nothing to do with Einstein
it's just that people suddenly decided
that they would name elements of the
famous scientists because they they'd
run out of names of America and places
like that I seem to remember a GCSE
level I don't even think the F elements
are on the periodic table I think they
are at a level onwards but you don't
really cover them they're just this
exotic bunch of crazy elements that do
bizarre things really interesting
bizarre things but you really don't come
into contact with them for a long time
in your career and it's only when you
get past a certain point say if you've
already got a PhD and you're on doing
postdoc anarion actual academic that you
can get into research groups who handle
these kind of elements on a routine
basis I still get people in the streets
shouting hello Einstein add me when
they're suitably drunk why did I do that
what I spective you do you think is
Einstein asked I'm not sure though I
have started the habit of sticking out
my tongue at people but not in the
street I think it's the funny hair and
the glasses and the fact that I look
like what they think scientists ought to
look like